hey 42 here farmer moves from the bright
lights of normal human civilization in
some of the darkest recesses of Earth's
great expanse our spine tingling and
hellishly creepy places that even the
most intrepid of adventurers don't
wander here's the seven creepiest places
on earth first up is how a Bakiyev
forest in romania this place is like the
Bermuda Triangle of forests the forest
is renowned in Romania for its spooky
and paranormal happenings situated in
north Romania the spooky wilderness has
been home to ghost sightings UFO
sightings disappearances and faces
appearing in photographs that weren't
there when the photo was being taken
people who visit the forest often report
an overwhelming feeling that they are
being watched visitors to the forest get
unexplained rashes and sometimes fall
ill electronic devices often refused to
work inside the forest the locals tell
stories of the first ever reported
paranormal case in the forest they claim
a shepherd mysteriously disappeared near
the forest along with his entire flock
of 200 sheep but that was only the start
in the 1960s a biologist named Alexander
rusev who was studying the forest took a
series of unbelievable photos of a
disc-shaped object hovering in the sky
above the forest again in 1968 military
technician Emil Binet captured another
infamous photo of a flying saucer over
higher bakiyev forest there have been
numerous reports of people going missing
in the forest and many people who visit
the forest report seeing over worldly
apparitions this has led many people to
believe that the forest is a portal to
another dimension next up we go to Japan
for another horrific Lee bizarre forest
but this one has a bit more of a Mack
obliga see o Kekaha a forest sits
silently at the base of Mount Fuji it
may look harmless but this one's a bi
o Kekaha a ferrous is known locally as
suicide forest that's because every year
people travel here in their droves just
to commit suicide every year over 100
people commit suicide in okie guru
forest most victims of the forest
disturbing a law hung themselves from
the tree branches the worst bit is that
the problem is not getting any better
every year the number of suicides in the
forest increases annual body searches
have to be conducted by police and
volunteers to seek out and remove the
hundreds of corpses of the unfortunate
souls that the forest has claimed
nowhere else in the world do people so
habitually commit suicide by hanging in
a single location at least not in these
disturbingly high numbers this
irregularity has led locals to erect
signs in the forest urging people not to
kill themselves the signs contain words
of optimism such as your life is a
precious gift from your parents and
think of your family no one quite knows
for sure why this particular expanse of
trees is chosen as the final resting
place for hundreds of people each year
what a nerve compels them to choose o
Kekaha a forest some say it's because of
a 1960 novel called courage acai which
is about a young lover who commits
suicide in oka Kihara forest Poveglia
island and the Venetian Lagoon Italy is
said to be one of the most haunted
places on earth located only a stone's
throw away from the romantic utopia that
is Venice sits in islands that is a
stark contrast to the captivating guise
of water bound Laura's Poveglia island
is known as plague island because it was
used as a quarantine station for people
who had to play over a hundred and sixty
thousand plague sufferers were sent to
this island to be isolated from society
about 95% of those people never left the
island because when they died from the
plague on the island which was most of
them they were burned or buried right
there on the island
mass graves were made on the islands and
thousands upon thousands of corpse were
dumped on top of one another and even
burned or
left to rot so many human remains were
disposed of on this island that the soil
is said to consist of 50 percent human
ashes perfect for growing turnips I here
so yeah that's disturbing but there's
more
as if this island hadn't seen enough
tragedy between 1922 and 1968 there was
a mental asylum on the island the doctor
at the asylum tortured and killed his
own patients he would also conduct
horrific experiments on them until he
eventually went crazy and killed himself
by jumping out of the bell tower of the
asylum chapels are meant to be places
for contemplation and redemption but not
this one unless you prefer to say your
prayers amongst the dead because this
Chapel in Portugal is lined from head to
toe in human skeletal remains this
Chapel aptly named the Chapel of bones
contains the bones of 5,000 monks and to
top it off there are two bodies hanging
from ropes inside the chapel and one of
them is the body of a child if you
happen to have a twisted fetish for
human bones you might also be interested
in the Sedlec ossuary similar to the
Chapel of Bones this small chapel in the
Czech Republic is covered in human bones
seriously why do people keep making
things out of bones I'll tell you what
because so many people were being buried
there that the priests ran out of space
so they decided to decorate the chapels
interior with their bodies instead
lovely oh they even made furnishings
with human bones too wood and nails are
so overrated
next to Scotland this creepy bridge
called Overtoun bridge is haunted by a
mysterious unknown force that wills dogs
to their death for unknown reasons
hundreds of dogs have spontaneously
committed suicide on this bridge by
jumping off it hundreds of dog owners
have reported walking their beloved pet
along this 15 metre tall bridge when
suddenly the dog goes crazy and leaps
off the side of the bridge without
warning the cases always happen around
the same point along the bridge
over 50 dogs in the past 50 years have
taken their own life in the exact same
way on Overtoun bridge so what is
causing these animals to kill themselves
after all dogs are usually rather happy
little fellas
it's largely unheard of for a dog to
take their own life is it an evil
spirits haunting the bridge or just the
sight of the bridge just freak them out
in Celtic mythology Overton is known as
the Finn place an area where heaven and
earth are said to be very close
some believe dogs are more sensitive to
paranormal forces and if Celtic
mythology is correct this bridge is
flooded with both good and evil spirits
however scientists who have studied the
bridge have a more rational explanation
they found a colony of mink that reside
underneath the bridge the minks powerful
anal glands leave scent marks wherever
they go and this smell has proven to be
irresistible to dogs during trials so
the most likely explanation is that the
dogs are uncontrollably drawn to the
enticing scent of musty mink a nurse
below the bridge under wise to the
dangers of high places they throw
themselves off the bridge in pursuit of
the smell sadly betrayed by their own
noses in Columbia County Pennsylvania is
a borough called Centralia that is a
real live ghost town in 1981 Centralia
had a population of over 1,000 today it
has a population of just 10 so what
happened where did everyone go
Centralia used to be a thriving coal
mining community in 1962 a fire started
in a mine beneath the town which is not
good considering the entire town sits on
top of a huge vein of coal the townsfolk
tried everything they could to put the
fire out
including smothering it with water and
even covering it in clay but they
continue to burn regardless the fire
quickly spread to numerous other mines
underneath the town then the ground all
over the town started to collapse due to
the immense heat coming from the fire
raging away evil low growl
pavement started to crack and crumble
houses collapsed without warning and
sinkholes appeared in random locations
engulfing buildings and people the
people of Centralia decided that the
town was no longer safe to live in and
with no hope of ever extinguishing the
fire everyone left apart from ten
stubborn people who refused to leave
most of the buildings have either
collapsed due to the fire or being left
abandoned for nature to take over today
Centralia is a near ghost town the main
road which passed through the town has
been blocked off because it's too
dangerous signs have also been erected
throughout the town warning people of
the severe dangers posed by the
never-ending underground fire it is
estimated that at its current rate the
fire will continue to burn for another
250 years
just south of Mexico City in the middle
of a swamp like canal sits the creepiest
island in the world named isla de las
Monica's which translates his island of
the dolls this terrifying place is
covered in child's dolls and not the
pretty card either nope this island is
decorated with hundreds of horrific
possessed dolls that totally won't
hesitate to murder you in your sleep so
the obvious question has to be asked why
the hell would anyone do this well the
story goes like this the islands
caretaker and its only inhabitant Don
Julian Santana Barrera found a little
girl in the waters of the island who had
drowned under mysterious circumstances
she was found with a doll floating
nearby Julian picked up the doll and
hung it from a nearby tree as a mark of
respect for the deceased girl but one
creepy doll wasn't enough for Julian
apparently the spirit of the little girl
haunted him and to appease the spirit he
started to hang more dolls and trees
before long he had covered the entire
island with hundreds of dolls Julian
started to believe that all adults were
possessed by the spirits of dead girls
and this slowly drove him to insanity
after fifty years of collecting and
hanging up dolls
Julian was found dead in
water he had mysteriously drowned in the
exact same spot where the little girl's
body was supposedly found all those
years ago some say that the little girl
never actually existed and Julia made up
the entire story as a way of coping with
his isolation on the island but no one
really knows the truth thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2